so the mic turned off here but
still so now does it work yes I think it
does
e
yeah
going through teams to see if it's
started
right hello everybody good afternoon and
uh welcome to today's planning committee
meeting here in the new chamber I know
we had a meeting here before Christmas
but before we start I would like the
Clark to just say a few words about the
new microphone system thank you
all right thank you chair um as members
will recall from the uh last uh meeting
there was a considerable amount of
feedback from the microphones at least
uh in the initial parts of it we think
that might have been due to the uh
number of uh um computers on the tables
next to the microphone so you'll
probably see today that no one has got a
um uh sort of laptop or tablet with them
um so from that point of view hopefully
and if any members need uh a copy of the
hard hard copy of the agenda we do have
some um so from that point of view this
hopefully will sort of uh be um uh
feedback free if you do get any feedback
though what we have found is that just
by moving your microphone slightly it
can actually reduce that so it's just
just a sort of a little teething trouble
for the moment but hopefully that will
run fairly
smoothly um now as this is a quite a
small meeting um compared to say sort of
you know the full Council it might be
simplest if uh when members wish to
speak you just go back to the
traditional approach of just putting
your hand up until the chair recognizes
you uh once the chair re has recognized
you and asked you to speak then at that
point could you turn on your microphone
uh you'll probably um recall that
there's a couple of seconds delay but
the microphone will be live from that
point um and again we'll do the votes uh
using the uh electronic system on your
microphones there and just to remember
members uh reminder members is that
green is yes so in other words that
you're for the motion um red is no that
is you're against it and yellow is
abstain thank you
chair thanks for that
uh we have two applications on the
agenda today along with the report on
planning appeals I am happy with this
and intend to take the business in the
order set out on the
agenda uh we just need to check the live
stream has the live stream now started
yes yes chair uh the first item on the
agenda is apologies for absence have we
received any in advance
uh yes chair we've received apologies
from councelor D chetam who's been
substituted by councelor m jant
councelor s foret who's been substituted
by councelor C
gar uh apologies have also been received
from councelor P Elliot and councelor T
Lacy and then finally apologies have
been received from councelor D Hancock
who's been substituted by councelor P
windley thank you
chair thank you I think that concludes
all the apologies
uh the second item is Declarations of
Interest members are requested to
declare the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interest and all
other interest not already on their
register of interest in any item on the
agenda and withdraw from the meeting at
the appropriate
time do any members have any interest to
declare on receive
chair we now have the minutes of the
meeting held on Tuesday 5th of
December are we happy that they are a
correct record and we can agree them by
acclamation anybody yeah move it chair
move it
second yeah all in
favor thank
you let's approve the minutes then thank
you how colleagues that brings us up on
the uh main business for the for today's
meeting our two applications before we
start I would CL I would like the Clark
to explain for the benefit of members
speakers and those watching on YouTube
how we will deal with
them right thank you chair this is the
procedure for considering the business
this
afternoon the chair will introduce the
application
then ask the planning office to deliver
a brief presentation on the application
and highlight any representations that
have been
received uh the late representations
report has been published on the
council's website and hard copies have
been circulated to you members uh
earlier
today after this the chair will ask any
speakers to address the meeting there
are six speakers today they will all be
super speaking on the second
application speakers will each have
three minutes to put forward their
views there will be a reminder given by
the clerk when 30 seconds remain at the
end of the 3 minutes members of the
committee will have the opportunity to
ask the speaker questions if necessary
to clarify any points they have
made after the speaker has addressed the
committee and answered any questions
then they will be allowed to remain in
the meeting
but they will not be allowed to
participate further from this
point the chair will open up the meeting
for questions to officers a debate by
the committee and a determination on the
application by a vote as said previously
the votes will be taken using the voting
facility on your
microphones finally members this meeting
is being live streamed and a recording
will be placed on the council's website
please note that others may choose to
copy this recording thank you
chair thank you let's move now to the
first
application uh first application Ned
[Music]
23685 Clay
Cross in line with our normal practices
I'm going to ask the planning officers
to give a brief presentation showing any
photos and plans of the site I will
allow the officer to complete the
presentation consequently members unless
you have a a point of order that you
feel cannot wait could you please
reserve these or any questions about the
process until the
end so over to the officers for the
presentation oh yes on the
podium thanks chair Adrian's just going
to drive the presentation I'll just say
a few words so this application item one
so this is a retrospective appliation
for the replacement of the shop front at
628 broadley's at Clay Cross the site is
located within the Clay Cross Town
Center and the conservation area members
who attended the virtual site visit
yesterday were provided with a full
Suite of plans and site photos I'll
share a few of those with you shortly uh
Just for information a single
representation has been received from
councelor cpit supporting The
Proposal full comments can be seen in
the late reps
report the main issues for the
application are laid out in the office
of report to members and the
recommendation by offices is to
conditionally approve the proposed
development so this first slide you can
see the application site shaded Orange
it's located on Broadley and forms a
single shop with rooms above it's set
between two of the premises to the north
and south and as I've said it lies with
in the Clay Cross Conservation Area next
slide
please so this is just a bit more of a
zoomed out plan of the application site
and illustrates the site in context of
The Wider Town Center of Clay Cross
Broadley is to the west and You' got
Market Street which runs east to west to
the north of the
site the site opposite the application
site to the West the open space forms
part of the wide air Clay Cross Town
deal application that members might be
aware of so the next slide
please so this is the submitted site
location plan with the site edged in red
next slide
please this slide is a comparison
between the old shop front uh to the top
of this slide and the now installed shop
front at the bottom of this Slide the
original shop front was of a Timber
construction and that installed is of a
upvc construction
next slide
please so this photo is taken from
Broadley looking directly at the shop as
installed next slide
please so this photo is the neighboring
premises as you can see there's a
there's a Timber surround and doors but
wind upvc window inserts have been
installed next slide
please and this final slide is a photo
of the other neighboring property which
which is a modern upvc shop front
installed and that concludes the
presentation
chair thank you for that uh right
colleagues as we have no speakers on
this application we will now move
straight on to questions to the officers
as always I would like to keep this part
of our proceedings focused on getting
clarity about any points you are not
sure of once we have done this we can
then have our discussion about the
application
based on all that we have heard and read
has anybody got any questions for
officers
no right I'll open the floor for
debate does anybody Council look
personally I think it looks a lot better
than it used to look because those
wooden windows were in the right state
so there you
go yeah I fully agree with that
thanks for that and now uh we'll
uh I think we'll go straight to a vote
on this one I think it's probably
easiest we've ever done and I'll propose
it that we accept officer
recommendations okay all those in
favor right thank
you
right we now move on to our second
application uh which is
Ned 23
0609 STL
mtown I'm going to ask the uh planning
officer to tell us about any late
comments and to give a brief
presentation showing any photos and
plans of the site I will allow the
officers to complete their presentation
consequently members unless you have any
point of order that you feel cannot wait
could you please reserve these or any
questions about the process until the
end so hand over to I believe it's you
Adrian you thank you
chair terms of the the details for this
application just refer members to the
late comments report of yesterday which
included some submission of photographs
that the applicant had sent in post
completion of the report in terms of the
application chair it's comprises the
construction of a two-story dwelling the
construction of an external WC area and
also the construction of an outbuilding
to form a tractor store and
workshop and the site chair lies within
Countryside to the southeast of ashover
and to the east of mil town and you can
see the application
site outlined
there the slightly zoomed out version
there chair and you may recall yesterday
at site visits we discussed the passing
of the site to its West by a highway and
then just to the north there's a
Crossroads that you can see on the slide
there which comprises a t Junction of
metal Highway and then to the East
running to the southeast um a right of
way and just in terms of land ownership
chair the application site outlined in
red with the applicant's additional land
holding outlined in blue as referred to
in the officer report
chair as I say the applicant is seeking
consent to construct a dwelling which is
the center inverse L-shaped building to
its
Southwest the rebuilding of a a former w
C building and then to the Northeast the
workshop and tractor store be accessed
off the highway chair through a existing
access onto
halane this is a slide of the submitted
drawing showing the remnants of the
building that formerly occupied the site
chair we'll see more of this on the
slides in a second but the applicant is
seeking to construct that building as
the new dwelling house
and in
addition that is the new tractor
store and
workshop and then that is the new WC
that's proposed to the southwest of the
building so on site J did see yesterday
a number of photographs that the site
visits yesterday this is a selection of
those small selection of those this is
the newly
formed hard surface driveway with the
remnants of the former building to the
right hand side of that
photograph and a slightly different
orientation showing the remains of the
the former dwelling that occupied the
site again it's referred to in the
committee report of
officers that's a view taken from the
existing Highway it can show does show
the some remnants of the rest of the
building being currently supported by
the the scaffolding poles
and then just a couple of photographs
that the applicant submitted late on in
the consideration process Just for
information is that their chair showing
the the building and that's taken from
the access point into the site showing
the the building and the hard surfaced
access
track thank you
chair
uh right colleagues we have six speakers
on the application uh the first of which
will be the ward member counselor
weatherall if you'd like to take the
seat you've got to three minutes I
think I think you'll know how to use the
microphones okay oh I hope so thank you
chair and thank you committee um I'm
asking at this point for the committee's
uh expertise and good sense really to um
rule on this particular application I'm
not a planning expert but I have built
my own property buying a piece of land a
plot of land from Chesterfield burough
Council and I know what it's like to
build a family home and to live in it
for 20 years I was invited by the
applicant last summer to look at his
plans um for the plot and I could see uh
in my view that this would make a lovely
family home for someone um and I was um
very happy to support a local business
as
well I haven't really changed my view
although I am aware that there are some
objections the applicant has presented
at Parish
Council um and objections again were
clearly set out at the parish council
separately I've spoken to several Parish
counselors and they are generally
supportive of the applic ation um one
Parish counselor was
ambivalent um about the application but
most were were in
support I have couch couched the
community View and again uh
overwhelmingly uh the same view as me
that this would be a good place to
locate a family home for someone on that
plot um and would enhance the plot
considerably from its current state um
as I say I've weighed up pros and cons
I've listened to arguments to and
against for and against um and I still
hold my view um but I am not a planning
uh expert and I have no technical
ability at all this is a personal view
hope that's helpful
chair thank you hases anybody uh got any
questions Council or
El uh no you can take your seat thank
you
uh right the second speaker is Tom
shields uh who's an
objector uh chair the is a maximum of
three people can register to support and
three can register to uh oppose an
application however there are certain um
people certain categories of people who
have the right to speak come up make one
of whom with which is a ward counselor
and then also the member who called the
application in so from that case it is
still within the um parameters of the
council's new scheme thank
you right yes that's
correct uh right uh
Mr Shields um you've got three minutes
I'm Tom Shields from Jr planning I'm
speaking on behalf of ingred and Andrew
Marsh of neighboring Meadows Cottage
unlike many who support the application
my clients would be directly impacted by
the development I speak strongly in
objection to it the office's report
leaves no doubt that building an
entirely new house and out building that
is of similar size to a second house is
co holy country to planning policy
approval would be a huge departure from
the development plan there are no
material considerations that justify
such a start departure from policy the
only sound conclusion is that the
application must be refused as the case
officer's report makes clear the
proposal is for an entirely newb built
house commercial outb building outside
of any settlement in the open
Countryside and within a highly valuable
and sensitive landscape
the council has a healthy supply of
housing land in sustainable locations
the deail development in this highly
unsustainable location is entirely
contrary to the council's adopted
spatial strategy the application tries
to play on romantic notion of restoring
the former Farmhouse however the former
Farmhouse cannot be restored as it no
longer exists indeed no house has
existed here since
1961 the very limited remnants of the
former building are ruinous and have
caused no harm whatsoever to the
landscape
character aside from the principle of
development being unacceptable it would
also cause significant harm to the
character of this valuable rural
landscape the local Ward member has
correctly noted The prominent nature of
the site within this area of outstanding
landscape
character policy ss9 strictly defines
development that is acceptable in open
Countryside locations such as this the
prop proposal does not fall within any
of these categories the application is
not for the conversion or restoration of
any existing building the proposal is
simply a brand new development in a
field in a remote and unsustainable
rural location this is cont to policy
ss9 and the
mppf the domestication of the site would
cause significant visual harm the
introduction of Park cars cultivated
Gardens bin stores artificial lighting
and all the other trappings of a modern
property would be highly significant
permanent and irreversible the
introduction of artificial lighting
would be particularly harmful given the
isolated location of the site in an area
noted for Dark Skies the photographs we
provided taken at the time the
applicants purchased the property
clearly show the R completely
naturalized it is unfortunate that over
the past two years the applicant has
used heavy plant to try and change the
character of the site the presence of a
dwelling on the land over 60 years ago
which has long since been abandoned and
reclaimed by Nature provides no
justification for the proposed new
development in conclusion the
development proposal is wholly
inappropriate for this sensitive
isolated location The Proposal is
clearly contrary to the development plan
as made very clear by the council's
planning officer in the report the
application must be refused thank
you right members do we have any
questions Mr
shs uh I've got a question um how far
away is um your client's
property Sor phone back on it's the
immediate property to the South so
there's one field which uh to the south
of the application site which belongs to
my clients and then their house is just
to the south of that field so what what
are we talking in
distance
yards yeah 150 M right and and the
impact would be I'm just trying to get
understand what the impact well the
impact is the significant change to the
um to the Tranquility of the the
landscape and the undeveloped nature of
the site and the replacement of an
undeveloped Green Field um Pastor
pastoral site with a brand new house
with a substantially sized second
building within its grounds it would be
a significant can change to the uh the
both the appearance and the the impacts
of that site okay thank you Mr sh
anybody else got any
questions no thank you if you want to
take your seat
thanks uh right the next speaker is the
applicant Mr Robert
Sharp
right you've got uh three minutes thank
you thank you chair thank you for your
time I'd first like to clarify that the
office report lists five representations
objecting to the
development these are all from one
family and their pay consultant the
reality is the application is receiving
overwhelming support from the local
community as summed up in the officer's
report the application needs to satisfy
just two criteria firstly whether the
land qualif as previously developed I.E
land which is or was occupied by
permanent structure and secondly whether
the scheme would have negative impact on
the landscape whilst officers take the
view that the development would have a
negative impact on the landscape it is
the view of 34 local people that the
scheme will be a vast Improvement people
who have best possible understanding of
the side in the local
area whilst this is a subjective matter
I believe any impact compared to the
current development can only be
described as positive the report is also
very dismissive of any benefits to the
proposal no consideration is given to
the restoration of drystone walls an
important feature of the area and
supported in the local plan the
application shows a 12% gain in
biodiversity the restoration the
restored walls providing habitat for
Wild Life along with the addition of
wild flow meow and tree planting all of
B all of which being an advantage to the
current development the project would
satisfy lowcost house in as the self
build it is not possible for myself and
my family to afford a local re bedroomed
house having purchased a site on the
understanding the local plan encourages
the use of previously developed land we
are currently living in rented
accommodation what is possible is for me
to use my skill set and the materials on
site to rebuild a family home lowcost
housing in its truest
sense no Authority has given any
objection to the development with darish
council's archaeologist adding I know
that the proposals for the building are
sensitive and the supporting comments of
the residents ATT test to the
craftsmanship of the applicant and their
wish to generally develop sensitively
and sustainably which is to be
wholeheartedly applauded site already
benefits from Mains water connection and
a modern biod disc treatment plant is
both Compact and more than adequate for
a three-bedroom family home it is
continuously suggested that locals
should have a greater say in what
development should and shouldn't be
approved if the application put forward
today was declared democratically it
would be approved with an overwhelming
majority we have taken 18 months working
with the Lo locals who remember the
house as a dwelling and also being
occupied to come up with what is a very
sympathetic scheme and the best possible
use of the site moving forward 30
seconds remaining we are very proud of
the fact that it will be built back on
the exact same footprint of the original
house using all the original Stone if
the application is refused today it it
would be to the benefit of no one if
approved Not only would it provide a
local young family with a family home
much like the Roberton family before it
would be proven to benefit the local
Wildlife along with the local res
who have shown their support thank you
for your
time uh thank you right members uh
members have any question for the
speaker
okay thank you chair uh and thanks for
that Mr Sharp uh I'll ask this question
because it's a question about policy I'm
not asking this question it might be a
difficult question okay and I'm not
asking this question to put you on the
spot but I'm asking it to give you a
chance if if you know what we're
considering as uh as a committee because
we you I'm spoken about policy when we
look at whether we're uh inclined to uh
go with officer's recommendations or
against officers recommendations and the
decision we're trying to what we're
trying to work out here is how it works
with policy so what I'm looking at is
policy ss9 that's what I'm considering
ss9 and
sdc3 now you might have read those I'm
guessing you don't have them to hand I I
understand that I'm not wanting to put
you on the spot but where do you think
we could consider it fits within our
policy to be able to Grant this um I'll
be asking the same questions of of
officers uh later when we get a chance
but to me it seems to center around
whether it's a new new dwelling a
ruinous building uh and these various
descriptions that we've got from
officers in our report so thank you for
that chair so my question is really to
give the uh the applicant a chance to
talk about policy and how I can consider
giving it permission because we've got
ss9 one one a to I 2 3 and then sdc3 so
anything you've got on that that had
help me thank you well as summed up in
the officer's report it it pretty much
hinges on the fact of firstly whether
the land would qualify as previously
developed land land which is or was
occupied by a permanent structure we've
never argued that there's still a
building there but we would certainly a
permanent structure it most certainly is
so with if that could be satisfied that
the um the site would be described as
previously developed land from that if
the site would then um have no um I
forget I forget the no negative
impact than the current development I.E
the current ruin if from that it would
have no no negative impact then
permission could be granted on on those
two key propos and that is pretty much
what the officers report sums it up to
that so first box to take is whether it
can be classified as previously
developed land and then second from that
if it has not a not a greater impact on
the
landscape which we believe the
rebuilding of the ruin would certainly
not then that would answer that you know
allowing policy to allow for their
application obviously when it's referred
to constantly as a new
build it's not a new build in the modern
sense of the term because it's actually
it's a reconstruction of what was there
before but I appreciate that that
doesn't come up necessarily in policy
but at the same time um for it to be
able to reconstruct the house if it can
if it can qualify as previously
developed and then therefore show that
it would look better than the Cent ruin
and that aders to policy if that's if
that gives you any Clarity or any you
know certainly my understanding of the
situation it gives me your view and
thank you for that Mr sha thank you
thank you chair
councel
windley from from the from the very
first week of ownership and the land
owners here today I was aware of the B
sets on the side um p ology were out on
the very first week and before a bush
was cut or any grass was even stmed
picology did a full report of the site
assessing where badget sets were none
fall within the red application side at
all uh the ones in the badget report are
marked one's on the shed bound you with
the neighbor um and one further to the
gate um no immediate effect of the
badger sets would occur from the
development of the of the of the red
area um but again we've we've worked
alongside with PE ecology throughout
even to the point where we never we
never turned a stone until it was clear
that there was no Great Crested NES on
side because it was a possibility with
the local water courses so all all along
we've got a full paper trail of working
with PE ecology to make sure that
anything we do to the to the to the
wildlife is advantageous rather than any
disturbance
thanks Council d
hello there Mr Clark I'm just looking
through the images of the application
and although the buildings been in Ruins
since 1961 which is very clearly evident
uh was there any efforts made to uh get
images of what the buildings originally
looked like because from my point of
view you're constructing a new building
um has there been what efforts have been
made to maintain the character Beyond
you know looking at the original
building uh that was located on the side
um it was it was throughout my best
efforts I've tried to find original
photography of the building
unfortunately that's not been the case
um the local farmer who remembers it
best from knocking on the door and and
and remembers people living there
originally within the first weeks did me
a drawing of what the building looked
like now from from Tiding up the site
the walls that still sand give complete
evidence of um heads seals jams of all
the windows and location of all the
windows the location of all the doorways
and even the parts of the building that
have fallen give a complete layout of
how the building was set out uh the the
main building itself uh was completed by
a cowshed element towards U the most
northern um side and and and everything
sort of we've gathered as much evidence
as we can to make it uh a replica
wouldn't be the right word but to make
it as sort of as as close to the hay
Farm as it stood before and sort of the
evidence on site is is there to work
with but then again talk to people who
remember who remember it as it stood
okay and just as a very quick follow on
from that from the DCC archaeologist
report are you happy with everything the
archaeologists have said of of recording
uh the uh the archaeological elements
being INB built into the program of
ground clearance and reconstruction yeah
most definitely the only the only person
to date who has ever for on the site
doing any work he been myself or in fact
my children when we've done digging and
finding the kitchen sink the tole floor
the stone
fireplace and it's uh it's it's not a
blank canus but it's a it's it tells a
story the building does it as it stands
now and the the I would
encourage um expertise advice on um
documenting what is there now and
rebuilding there there are wire cut red
bricks that form the original
uh chimney uh which which we' we've sort
of slly picked out and we can start
which which I would love to use again to
to restack the stimy restack the chimney
and all the features that we can
incorporate back into the build I you
know I would I would I would encourage
and I would really I'd enjoy working
alongside an archaeologist and
documenting that okay thank you
thanks uh right thank you I'm don't we
got any more questions if you want to
retake your swe much thank you thank
you right the next speaker is Kathy
Clark thank you you've got three minutes
when you're ready
thanks excuse me could you um turn your
mic
on is that on now y okay so I start
again my name is Kathy Clark I've lived
in miltown for over 20 years and for
most of this time I've been working in
the construction industry specifically
for about 10 years protecting and
promoting traditional building skills
and then more recently a CEO of a
specialist trade organization within the
construction industry so I'm fully aware
of all the issues surrounding skills and
decent housing in the industry and I see
this proposal as a welcome Beacon of
light in a pretty dark tunnel to be
honest renovating rebuilding and
sympathetically reusing existing
building materials which contain so much
embodied carbon is vitally important to
our overall sustainability for someone
with the correct skills knowledge and
understanding you have a valuable and
important project for a sensitive site
such as this they couldn't be better or
more appropriate clients applicants he
and his family are skilled traditional
craft people who totally understand the
special nature of the land and the
buildings and who want to reconstruct a
modest sustainable family home on the
same
footprint so on looking at the documents
online I was just um so pleased to see
that my professional opinion um um is
matched by our locals and I plotted them
because I wanted to actually see where
they all lived and they all live locally
and there's lots of them I think they're
all here um there's 34 pound families
which support this application there's
just one family that doesn't they they
uh pass it off and then they see it and
I just wanted to highlight three
comments from three separate um
supporters here one I can remember the
Robinson family living at hay Farm I've
had tea in that kitchen its rebuilding
will enhance the local surrounding of
area of
Countryside two the cottage really
deserves to be brought back to life I'm
especially pleased to see how much
careful thought has gone into the plans
considering sustainability and ever
important ecological enhancements and
thirdly the proposal will be a welcome
addition to the local area providing a
family home for a community where
housing stock is low the two reasons for
objecting we've already heard um harmed
to the landscape and and doesn't
recognize it as an existing building the
first is purely subjective and the
second is false we can see it when I've
met Rob and his wife Hannah recently
Hannah said to me Cathy I can stand in
my kitchen on the Minon tiles I can look
out of the window I can turn left and I
can see the fireplace how can anyone say
this wasn't a
building we can't 30 seconds remain
although it's um ruin although it's
ruinous it is still quite clearly a
house and was a home within living
memory the local community
overwhelmingly support this proposal we
need more housing and this family will
be the best and most careful custodians
of the landscape that we could want you
have it in your gift here today to allow
this skilled and knowledgeable family to
reinstate a modest family home with the
highest craftsmanship ship
sustainability and Eco credentials that
will increase the biodiversity and
enhance the landscape not harm it thank
you for your
time uh thank you do uh any members have
any
questions the speaker no okay if you'd
like to retake your seat thank you very
much the next speaker is Martin how
another
supporter
right you've got three minutes when
you're ready thank you thank you uh my
name is Martin How I Live uh within a
quarter of a mile of the uh
proposal um and thank you for the chair
and thank you for the opportunity to
address the committee today um planning
officer recommendation here is based on
their opinion
alone that it is not previously
developed land the case rests almost
entirely on convincing elected members
and indeed the residents of the area to
accept this the report details a number
of policies under which development can
legitimately take
place and also states that other
relevant policy concerns can be
addressed by planning
conditions excuse me however each is
dismissed on the basis that this is not
previously developed land or the land
has blended into the landscape or has
now been assimilated into the
landscape the dwelling is shown on maps
as early as
1835 it was built as a house and
seemingly in continuous use for
approximately 125
years on the point of previously
developed land as you've heard the
dwelling has a kitchen Tire files and a
sink although strangely there's no
photographs of this in this
report the red hering of the dwelling
laterally being used for agricultural
purposes is also
inaccurate the previous owner of the
dwelling who is here
today has stated that the cow buyer
where the cows would shelter not the
house therefore perfectly legitimate use
of the surrounding
land it's acknowledged that the dwelling
was occupied until 1959 or thereabouts
and indeed local people can remember
this I don't believe there's a statute
on dwellings blending into the
landscape it seen time scales for
dwellings assimilating into the
landscape are also not defined I'm sure
they would have been included in the
report if they
were as previously stated this house was
a house for 125 years a reasonable yard
stick to use would be whether a dwelling
can be remembered as being inhabited and
utilized in its original state I.E
within living
memory the opinion stated by the
planning officer is merely that 30
seconds remaining it's not backed up by
fact National planning guidelines nedc
policy or the ashover neighborhood plan
however the whole acceptance of the
report and subsequent recommendation
hinges on that
in conclusion to say that this is not
previously developed land and has devel
and has blended into the landscape is
tenuous to say the least it's certainly
not strong enough grounds for
refusal thank
you thank you uh do any members have any
questions uh no if you like to retake
your seat thank
you uh the next speaker is another
supporter Karen
Haywood yeah you've got three minutes
when you're ready right thank you yes
I'm Karen Hayward I live at Brookside
Cottage gint Lane mtown next to the
miners arms if people know the miners
and very close to the Old miltown Quarry
I'm no stranger to planning committees
having previously objected to planning
applications that adversely affected
public rights away in my role as British
horse Society volunteer access officer
however in this instance I feel
compelled to support this local family's
application to rebuild the former
Cottage Farm as a resident of this
beautiful area for the last 28 years
I've witness the renovation of five der
Cottages within the miltown Quarry
curtilage since the the Quarry closure
over 20 years ago with two of the
properties being in a similar state to
Hay Farm a previous owner of Jin House
on Jin Lane can also testify that the
former two attached Cottages were in
state of dereliction over 30 years ago
so a local president has been set in
rebuilding deric dwellings these
improvements have only helped enhance
the visual aspect of the area as well as
providing much needed homes for families
although I'm not a customer of Rob sharp
and his family's joinery business I've
seen the excellent craftsmanship that
has been produced in several local
properties especially notable at the
miners arms Inn which has undergone
extensive and sympathetic restoration
over the last 20 years and
more having met Rob and Hannah a number
of times over the years I know that they
are passionate about the care of the
countryside and nature teaching their
two children all about the Laur and
forer at hay
Farm asera Parish Council has declared
its acknowledgement of climate change in
July 2020 stating that and I'm quoting
it is essential that this Parish Council
helps to Pro proactively facilitate the
protection of our local environment
Heritage and natural beauty promoting
sustainability healthy living and also
Prosperity within the
parish as a member of ashover Parish
climate change working group I can
safely say that the proposals for the
rebuilding of hay Farm will help fulfill
national and local planning criteria for
sustainable and environmentally friendly
design enhancing bio and
geodiversity there is overwhelming
support
for 34 support letters to see hay Farm
rebuilt in a traditional manner as
outlined in the
application several of these supporters
have been farming long farming ties
within the area and visited the Robinson
family at hay Farm over 60 years ago two
of the supporters Overlook the site we
live in a democracy I trust the
committee will take into account and
support what local people want to see
built in our community thank
you uh thank you do any members have any
questions no if you'd like to oh sorry
uh councelor
again I did wonder about the right way
it wouldn't have any an adverse impact
on the right of way that's quite close
it's fo path I and many people use and
and that's why we over the years after
you know I've all this time I've lived
there walked the dog that way many times
I've always wondered about this I
thought how how lovely it would be to
see this rebuilt run just crumbling away
and and and a family that can't be able
to afford land a lot of people can't
there all these executive homes been
built on Greenfield sites within our
parish and as half the people don't even
live there half time this family would
live there as a family home so no it'd
be lovely to see and I think most people
would uh really enjoy seeing it come
back to life thank
you thank you if you'd like to retake
your seat thanks uh right the last
speaker we've got on this uh this is
George enaw the
agent thank you good afternoon good
afternoon you've got three minutes yeah
okay thank
you uh sorry could you just turn your
mic
onk you I speak today as agent for the
application on behalf of the sharp
family
members will have read the officer
report the supporting documents will
have heard the impassioned views of the
applicant and local
residents with regard to policy ss9 of
your local plan it permits development
in the countryside where it involves the
ReUse or Redevelopment of vacant derate
or previously developed land which would
not have a greater impact on the country
side than the existing
development members are invited to use
their common sense as to the state of
the site and its condition
the dwelling house has been designed as
a faithful reconstruction of the
original Farmhouse and is no larger in
scale for the purposes of interpreting
policy ss9 members are invited to assess
the proposal against how the structure
existed in its last complete
form turning to the second reason for
refusal which alleges that the proposal
would result in significant landscape
harm the report identifies that the site
is visible from a number of land view
viewpoints across the valley in reality
the Topography of the landscape is that
the site is relatively well screened and
this was identified in the design and
access
statement the main Viewpoint towards the
site is from the
b636 towards willly Moore some 600
meters from the site and on Higher
Ground what one sees from this Viewpoint
is an interspersed collection of country
cottages and farmsteads dotted across
the hillside these buildings form an
intrinsic part of the landscape in this
part of the parish and Define the
settlement of mil
the rebuilding of a cottage which has
formed part of this landscape for over
200 years can only be seen as
representative of development in this
area and cannot be seen as
harmful once the scheme is considered to
be us by us to be policy compliant this
proposal is so unique it could not have
been reasonably foreseen by planning
policy approval of this application will
set no
precedent you misuse your discretion
having heard the merits of the scheme
you have the power to acord these the
appropriate weight in the planning
balance knowing that this proposal
constitutes exceptional
circumstances I note that neither of the
statut consules have objections that
would cause you to refuse the
application indeed the view of the
county council's archaeology team that
the proposal should be wholeheartedly
supported is a testament to the
application before you this
afternoon I would therefore kindly
invite you to vote against your officer
report and to approve the application
today thank you very much for your time
thank you uh do any members have any
questions please what the use of the
workshop is I meant to ask the owner
both didn't what is he going to use the
workshop for yes I'd like to address
that um so thank you um the the work my
my my client is a joiner um and has a
joining Workshop towards tanley and
Matlock um essentially in order to
maintain the land um is intended that
the the workshop is used as a tractor
store and workshop um it would be no
more intrusive intrusively used as a
workshop it would be similar in in scale
to a essentially a shed at the bottom of
the garden and there would be no power
tools used in in in the workshop so
there would be no commercial deliveries
of Timber it is essentially it's I mean
it's similar in scale to a garage but it
would be used mainly for maintaining the
land and essentially as as an out
building for in in use with the dwelling
house
thank you any more
questions no if you'd like to retake
your seat then
please uh right then colleagues uh you
now have the opportunity to put
questions to the officers about the
application can't thank you um just a
bit of a I'm a little confused why
you've described it as
isolated um because I had a quick run
around at the weekend and on that lane
are approximately 15 properties which I
don't class as
isolated uh it's a mile from um to
Wymore which has 122 houses it's a mile
to
the uh hamlets of miltown and the hay
which have 161
properties also remote from local
Services 1.7 miles to the center of
ashover where there's doctors Church
three pubs two shops a butchers a play
school and a school now I have to go
three miles to my doctors so I do not
class that as isolated maybe I know it's
all appropriate to probably to where you
are where you come from Etc but I do not
class that position of that former prop
Farm as isolated under any circumstance
I'm just a bit confused why that has
been put and the um remote from local
Services I just don't agree with that at
[Music]
all chair the the view of offices on
that point is set out as Council Le gets
aware
it
Adan you need to use
your is it your
[Music]
phone
you try this go
there
The View on the issue of isolation is
set out as you'll be able to read it
paragraph
8.10 and in terms of the way that the
site is situated in the countryside it
does stand alone and in the view of
officers that constitutes an isolation
in terms of the the issue with regards
to Services it is again as as you've set
out it lies away from settlements and it
would require the use of a car or other
vehicle to get to those those services
so it's in that context that officers
concluded the the isolation of
it okay well I'm I'm I completely
disagree with that because I think 1.7
miles to the center of a very very
thriving Community is not isolated also
it's 600 m
um from the nearest bus stop which is on
that road the main road into in and out
of ashover I I think I could do it in
about 10 minute walk to the bus
stop again chair just just in terms of
that the the issue of um sustainability
isolation Etc would be a combination of
all those factors how easy is it for um
an ordinary person to get to to access
those services in this case as as you
know because you've been for
a trip around the area you would need a
car to to get to those Services there's
there's no footways that connect it to
settlement so you will be walking along
Lanes or other tracks and not be able to
to access a pavement facility for
example and as you say it's 600 meters
from a bus stop so all those factors we
would take into account in our
conclusion as as officers on that factor
chair thank you Adrian Council
Doran thank you you
sh looking at Point 8.7 uh I'm just
going to quote it uh it is the view of
officers that in this case the land does
not qualify as previously developed land
as the remains of the building and fixed
structure and infrastructure have
blended into the landscape as is evident
in the photographs displayed as is the
case over many years I I I'm I'm
struggling with this because I'm looking
at the pictures supplied in the main
pack as well as the more recent photos
and to my eyes to to to my lay person's
eyes that is not the case at all these
have not blended into the structure M
itself the the wall itself has having to
be held up by
scaffolding um this looks very obvious
and we I think all of
us have seen in the countryside these
derel buildings so could you elaborate a
little bit more on 8.7 as to why you why
the officers feel and their opinion
these buildings have been reclaimed by
the land thank
you just um refer members primarily to
figure nine on page 35 which I think
shows that point clearly bearing in mind
that that photograph was taken at least
a decade ago so bearing that in mind but
in certainly in the eyes of officers
that would constitute a structure that
has Blended back into that that pastoral
landscape and is not um an uncommon
feature of other collections of of
stones or other building materials that
may also have have simly Blended back
into auroral character and it the point
we we have um tried to make in the
report is that that was the the scene
and that it's not as is at the moment
because as you've heard that there has
been the the removal of um grass and and
other um trees Etc that were were on the
site so what you see now is very much a
sanitized version of what there was
there previously so so in the views of
officers that collection of of stones
and Associated materials has
deteriorated such that it is being
reclaimed by the landscape and has been
such and as or was certainly before the
site was um worked on was very much the
way that that that form of structure was
viewed and H our conclusion in terms of
that that PDL issue thank you CH could I
just follow on a little bit with that if
you don't mind uh thank you
so I'm looking at figure uh nine and
figure 10 now um so is it the officer's
opinion that the O the current owner of
the land uh the applicant uh was not
really permitted to remove though that
that that grassland that Shrubbery uh
into created into its current state as
shown as figure 10 um
is that what you're saying here that
they shouldn't have done
that I've not not taken that step all
that I'm trying
to say in answer to your question is
that from the point of view of officers
our view that was that before the site
was worked on the situation was less
sanitized than it is now in terms of
what you can see in figure 10 for
example where um there are the
scaffolding poles that have been put up
to to I presume prop up elements of the
building where the site's been stripped
and where working has taken place I
presume to reclaim the materials to to
stack them and store them whereas that
was very much a more pastoral
and natural state back when I don't
recall the site um myself previously and
that is the the latest street view image
that that we have at 2009 but the
situation would have
added to that as time would have gone on
each year would have would have followed
on and bearing in mind that's 10 years
ago which is about 15% of the lifetime
from when the building was last used it
is quite a considerable period of time
that would have elapsed since
then no no the building was last
occupied we understand 1959 so that's
that's the 60 years so so 10 years would
be 15% roughly 15% of that so um it
would have gone on another 10% beyond
that so that that's our that's why we've
concluded that the the remnants of that
structure assimilated back into the
surroundings that rural character that
personifies this area thank you uh
councilor Foster thank you chair uh yeah
my question centers around much the same
thing as the the council has previously
said and I'm looking for clarity
really uh from officers on this uh we're
being asked to uh go with your
recommendations based on ss9 and sdc3
but ss9 first uh when we look at that
and we look at comments made by uh made
by speakers and we look at definitions
that's what's important to me we've
heard it referred to as an existing
building uh We've also seen it referred
to as uh new build in the report but
we've also seen it uh mentioned on
4.4 by offices as the ruinous
building so I'm not just looking at
previously developed
land for counselors I'm looking on page
52 of our local
Plan ss9 F it involves the change of use
reuse limited infin or Redevelopment of
vacan derilict or previously developed
land so it can be
derel so what what I'm concerned about
is to give uh the applicant a fair crack
at this and that's why I spoke about
policy earlier this is what what we've
got to consider if we can have more on
that from officers more on uh because I
think that's fair is to mention uh
derilict land because if it were me uh
on the other side that's exactly what
I'd be speaking about it's not just that
it's previously developed it's derel and
we're referring it in our own report as
a ruinous building so if you can expand
on that for me to be able to help me
make a decision if you say to me for
example not put words into your mouth no
it's not a building it's a collection of
stones as you said but we've also got it
mentioned in an officers report as a
ruinous building so it's around that if
that makes
sense I'll try and take um each of those
points if I can recall so please tell me
if I've not not addressed them first of
all you're you're right that you need to
assess where you are in terms of the
council's policy it's development plan
in in determining this and if the
proposal is in accord or cont to
development plan do you then go to other
matters so you're quite right you
concentrate first of all primarily on on
your development plan in terms of ss9 f
it goes through those various stages and
you particularly asked about the issue
of dereliction ruinous collection of
stones my my
own view is the applicant is not relying
on the Reconstruction of a building he's
he's talking about it's starting again
in effect starting from nothing so he's
not talking about a conversion of an
existing structure so he's already gone
beyond that so in terms of of this this
the site itself my view is that it is a
collection of stones that roughly
resemble parts of a of a former building
so in that term it is ruinous and as
you'll have read officers there
therefore conclude there is no building
left it's it's gone by reason of age and
deterioration the issue of dereliction
we've dealt with in terms of paragraph
8.8 of the report where we're saying
that the term derel using the mppf is a
in the context of despoiled or degraded
land and we've taken the view that when
it's given its ordinary natural meaning
that that means um des spoilation
and dereliction to me would be um areas
that just looked neglected and of of no
have no love left with them and in this
instance the view that we've taken is
that the building is has gone and it has
then been reclaimed by by the the area
by the the landscape and is assimilated
back into it so the view is that we that
our view is that it isn't that
dereliction it's gone beyond that in
terms of the the state that it's that
it's now in however the point that is
important here and again we mentioned
this in the report is that the policy
then talks about the next step so even
if you were to disagree with officers on
the point of dereliction
vacancy previously developed land the
next step is that it shouldn't have a
greater impact on the character of the
countryside than the existing
development so even if you were reminded
to disagree then you need to take that
next step for it to be one of the
categories of development in the
countryside that is supported because
that's how the policy is written it's
that certain developments will be
approved where it can be demonstrated a
b CDE E F G H or I so it's it's not
those that will ordinarily be um allowed
it's supported so it it's a slight
different wording but in terms of
paragraph F it's even if you were to
disagree with officers on the point of
dereliction it shouldn't have a greater
impact on the character of the country
side and officers are of the view the
very clear view that a new
dwelling a new build building for
storage tractor keeping or or whatever
use um maintenance of the land and the
WC building and the associated
infrastructure the
gardens um the driveway the pathways Etc
that would have a significantly greater
impact on the character of the
countryside than the existing
development and then that falls beyond
that on policy S3 which you mentioned
previously in terms of what is the
character of that area at the moment
which is of a field with
um a collection of stones within it and
that would be replaced by house the
other point that and I appreciate um you
didn't mention this exact so if you just
bear with me but there's also policy ap2
of the neighborhood plan which is
referenced in the the reason for refusal
and that talks about certain elements of
developed in the countryside in terms of
the ashover neighborhood plan that will
be permitted in terms of this particular
scheme that in my view and that view of
of officers wouldn't fall with any of
those definitions of a b or c of that as
well so I hope that's that's helpful and
gives a clear view of where that we
would stand as
officers can I come back chair yeah uh
thank you thanks very much for that
Adrian appreciate that uh there's a
there's a lot here in this with I follow
exactly what you've said I understand uh
the the uh the de Devion issue and then
we got the greater impact on the C of
the country side I understand that as
well this is quite a it's quite a
lengthy thing and uh there's an awful
lot for the committee to consider here
an awful lot and this report while it
gives us an idea and it helps us make
that decision if for example I were to
think that yes this fits uh the Devion
so we can pass that test there's not
enough H in here for us to be able I
don't think as a committee to be able
to carry on making those decisions and
going down those steps if we were minded
to be granting uh going against officers
recommendations and wanting to give uh
permission to uh to this development so
it doesn't feel quite Fair uh in my view
uh just how it's constructed and how
much there is to look at uh and I'll
give my view straight away uh I would
consider it uh derelict that'd be my
view but I don't feel as I've got enough
in front of me and enough time and
enough consideration to be able to go on
through the various steps and then sdc3
what I'm not wanting to do is give a
flat no to an applicant and no um no
light at the end of the tunnel here
because my own view is that this could
tick one of the boxes and then later on
perhaps we could consider other parts of
this that that that's that's that's my
view it's not a question to officers but
but that's my view from what from from
where we are now so thank you
chair
any more questions for
officers
nope uh right thank you to that thank
you for that um this leads us to the
final part of the process and process
our discussion about what we heard what
we think and what we want to decide I
would now like to open the floor for
debate
Council thank you
um personally and I like I say I do know
that road I've ridden up and down it for
years as well and in my opinion what
he's done already has been an
improvement to the landscape I mean you
can see on that last photograph that
drystone wall that's been rebuilt has
been done to an extremely high standard
and it's a shame from these photographs
you can't quite see that in perspective
of the rest of the
surroundings uh because there like I say
there were another 15 or so properties
on that street on that lane um and I
just don't think I personally and I love
ashover with a passion and I love that
that Valley and that Countryside and I
really don't feel that that would be
hurting the landscape I really
don't and I'm Mrs no build as you know
but uh I don't I honestly don't think
that that would hurt that landscape not
from what I've heard from people that
know the applicant and what I've seen
myself as have been
passed thank you Council L anybody else
want to contribute to this
debate yes a just just one thing if I
may chair um grateful for Council Li for
alluding to it actually but just to ask
members to be very careful in how much
weight you place on the issue of the
applicant and what you've heard about
him the application would stand on its
own
merits and whilst you may have heard
those issues around the applicant and
and his his abilities his skills his
business the way he's he's seen in the
community there would be nothing that
would tie any permission you were to
Grant this afternoon for example to him
to undertake The Works to live there Etc
so I just ask members to be guarded in
how much weight you place on that
particular issue in your determination
this afternoon just be very careful in
in the the emphasis you place on that
thank you
chair it's just just to confirm what I'm
sort of trying to say is uh I don't
think that rebuild of that would be any
more harm than the other 15 or so
properties on that
lane thank
you Council
dorant thank you chair I'm having a hard
time with with this application if I'm
if I'm honest because I I I'm looking at
the street view what uh the officers
have pulled through and I'm I'm looking
at street view myself now and it's to me
when I look at it from different angles
when I'm going along on on on the map
here I can see the old photo from 14
years ago it's sticking out more than
that single photo depends on the angle
you're looking at so I'm having a hard
time with that uh there's a few other
things I'm having a hard time with um I
would say that any consideration of us
accepting um the application and
rejecting the officer's recommendation
would need to come in line with what uh
darash County Council uh of uh
archaeologists have said uh because
there's not been a lot of cons I haven't
seen a lot and we would I think we would
need to put that in the proposal uh
there's a there's a note of anything
note on that um the difficulty I'm
having as well though is looking at the
original buildings footprint and then
looking at the proposed new build
rebuild however we want to call
it um is larger than the original
building the there is that um garage on
the side and so I'm I would I'm throwing
that out there that that side building
I'm um
here that I'm having a hard time with
accepting that one uh just to stir
debate on this um but in terms of
regenerating and uh effectively I I
agree with fellow counselors this is
derelict looking at it from other angles
I think this was been der for a while I
I do accept members of the public saying
that they that this was a der piece of
land I I can't agree with the officers
from a l perspective that this this
wasn't this was fully reclaimed and also
I never felt like we got an answer that
the owner of the land was permitted to
cut back on that Greenery um that I
think I think I'm I'm following up a
little bit on that but those are my
difficulties I'm having with this
application so I'm throwing those out
there to try and stir up debate on to
see what other councilors think on
this thank you
coun yes
C I'm still bothered about this work
shop thing is it domestic in what
respect is it domestic and how
or is it as he is a join is this going
to become
industrialized it's there isn't it
doesn't appear to be a plan on the site
for that out building I can see the
footprint of the house but
not a footprint for the out building is
there one can you is
there yeah please I let to Adrian
respond to that and then I'll bring you
in just just in terms of the the out
building chair I'm I'm not aware of the
provision or otherwise of associated
buildings in association with the house
so I can't help on that I'm afraid
there's there's nothing that seems to
suggest from what's left there that
there was another building or um a
structure in where the the shed is what
what I will say in terms of the the
detail is that in the the original
submission made by the applicant and his
agent there is is reference to the the
out building being a live work unit in
association with that join business um
although um Sue advised me that there's
been during consideration of the
application there has been a rowing back
of that from the applicant in terms of
it just being an Associated domestic
building but in terms of that either way
just reference the comments that
councelor Foster and I have had in
respect of that that that would come
along with the as it stands that would
come along with the the new house and
all the associated trappings of
Domesticity that would would go along
with that so it's a bit more than just
just the house but in terms of the other
buildings other than the former house I
can't advise on that other than there
doesn't look as there there's anything
left on site of any other any other
structures any other substantive
structures anyway
thank you Adrian um
Council uh just following following on
from my counselor um are we able to put
it's a question really uh a question for
the
officers in these plans are we able to
put restrictions on the use of that out
building or is it we accept or decline
and so the applicant could then use them
for commercial use if they wish or could
we put restrictions on
that you could buy condition chair if
you minded to Grant the the scheme in
its totality you could condition that
the outbuilding in fact any of the
buildings were only used for domestic
purposes not for any industrial or
commercial activity and then if the
applicant chose to undertake that in a
manner that's not ancillary to the use
of the dwelling house as such then a
formal Grant of planning permission
would be required for that that dual use
if you
like
councilor Foster thanks chair Adrian my
questions around sdc3 uh reading it um
if we can have some clarity on that it
looks like this pertains to new
development would this still apply if we
as a committee thought that this
qualified as derelict or previously
developed land because that's one of the
reasons giving in the recommendations
for
refusal if you can take me through that
the the issue of of landscape character
landscape quality would follow on from
subsection two of policy ss9 because you
have to go the next step in terms of in
all cases it shall be sympathetic to the
character of the area so then you would
have the additional consideration of was
this scheme sympathetic to the
distinctive landscape character being it
um an area of multiple environmental
sensitivities so of the highest
landscape quality of Northeast starer
and as we've set out in the report in
the view of offices in this case because
of what's what's said that it is a
valued landscape in in terms of national
National guidance so um that's why we've
set the second reason aside from the
first reason because it's a different a
different conclusion if you like the two
distinct elements so that's why we've
set that aside in those in in those
terms so hopefully this brings that all
together in answer to your question sdc3
would be a consideration and you would
need to be happy whichever way you went
on the application that it conformed
with policy sdc3 in particularly in
respect of its primary aims
categorization in your local plan I hope
that's maybe I've lost myself a bit
within all that not just lost
you and same question around AP ap2 of U
ashop neighborhood plan please
if you can en US a bit more I'll take us
through
that in terms of the the local plan
policy it's very specific in terms of
what the the neighborhood plan for
ashover sets out in that outside
settlement limits which this site Falls
outside settlement limits development
proposals would be carefully controlled
and it says limited to then there's
three categories supporting the rural
economy and need to be in the
countryside provision of affordable
housing to demonstrable need on a rural
exception site and then the ReUse of
redundant or underused buildings and
then in all cases not seriously be
intrusive in the countryside respecting
the character of existing settlements
and their setting so from an officer
point of view we we include that in our
our reasons for refusal but in the view
of officers it wouldn't fall within any
of those categories a house doesn't need
to be located a new house doesn't need
to be located here it's not for the
provision of a aable hous would be
controlled as such and we've concluded
it's not a building so we would we would
say it falls foul of neighborhood
planning policy
ap2 uh thank you any more
questions anyone else want to cont well
I'm going to contribute to I'm a little
bit I am a little bit sympathetic to the
application um I've been driven up there
and had a had a look at the site uh and
looked at the views from the B road that
runs through to
woore uh and I can see the you can see
it it from from that location but um as
Council liot mentioned there are lots of
other properties that you also can see
from that that
location
um one thing I am concerned about is I
don't think the add-on on the end of the
building uh in fig four the pro proposed
East
Elevation um the wooden structure at the
end I'm not convinced that's that's in
keeping with how the building would have
been um and I'm also concerned about the
size of the out building and why we need
an outside WC in uh
2024 so
um but apart from that
I I can understand where they're coming
from to to actually bring this back into
some use as far as the outside WC I've
got one and we use it a lot it's very
handy when you're gardening and you're
out in your field you don't have to take
your o
off so um that's uh that's just what I'd
like to add but I do I do think the out
building is oversized and I'm not
convinced the uh uh add-on part of the
building with the wooden structure is is
uh is necessary but I have noticed that
there are other properties in the
location that have got um um
conservatories added to them
so so that's what I'd like to add
anyway nobody else want to enter into
the debate right thanks colleague um I'm
going to um ask Alan to clarify I'll do
from over there okay yeah oh
[Music]
do see if it works yeah
just want him to clarify a
motions right thank you chair uh please
bear in mind members that a motion must
be moved and seconded before a vote is
taken if an amendment to a motion is
moved and seconded then that Amendment
will be voted on
first if a motion is to be moved which
goes against the officer's
recommendations then the member who has
moved the motion must give the reasons
for doing
so the reasons for removing a motion
against officer recommendations should
comprise the relevant planning issues
and be supported by evidence as
necessary if a motion to reject officer
recommendations Falls or in other words
it is not passed that doesn't mean that
the recommendations are automatically
approved rather you will need to take a
positive decision through a further
Motion in favor of the recommendations
or a different course of action
this will need to be approved through
the committee through another Bose thank
you
chair thank you Al thanks colleagues
having heard everything uh and read
everything today and the officer's
recommendations before us what is the
view of the committee on the
application uh I am now opening the
floor to
motions
no nobody's got anything to put forward
conditions
maybe Council
d as I said before um earlier on if we
view took the view to reject the
officer's um
recommendation in my view that would be
on the grounds that this uh I don't
accept that this is isn't uh been
reclaimed by the land that it is in fact
a derel site um I would agree with you
with what you said before chair uh as I
alluded to myself I believe that the
side wooden building is excessive and
that I would condition that that part be
rejected similarly I would I would say
that we attach a condition that any
reconstruction and uh ground clearance
be inbuilt with uh darish County Council
archaeologists uh recommend ations which
was uh elaborated on by themselves in
5.6 and I would also reject the the out
building as well that is my own personal
position that it that uh that the
building itself be allowed to be rebuilt
but the the out building and the side
building be rejected uh with the
conditions along with the
archaeologist
put together ruling I am quite happy to
put that
forward okay do you want to clarify just
um very briefly shair just um if I'm
understanding councelor Durant correctly
the house and the WC and all the other
elements are acceptable but it's the
storage building that wouldn't be
acceptable if that if I'm concluding
correctly if I'm understanding correctly
I believe that you would either the need
to defer the application to allow
discussion on the application and that
to be considered and accepted or Not by
the applicant and has come back or you
would be refusing the application on the
back of the outbuilding alone not being
acceptable I don't think you could issue
a a split decision in terms of those
those details I think they would be your
two options I'm Guided by colleagues if
they think I'm incorrect I think that
would be that would you you would need
either to defer and allow officers to go
back on that basis to the applicant and
allow them to consider that agree or not
and come back or to refuse the
application of the unacceptability of
that element
alone Council
voster thank you chair yeah that was
that was my view as well we've also got
to speak about policy for me for the
time I've spent on here we have to
address those policy issues ss9 and
SEC um
and I wouldn't want to create a
precedent here where we give permission
to a development without addressing
policy issues I think it's a really bad
precedent that I feel very supportive of
this as a development but I'm concerned
about what we do as a as a committee
chair uh and for that reason I'm happy
to uh propose a motion that we defer
this and we send it back to officers and
let officers go back to the applicant
and discuss discuss this further I think
for me I think hopefully that uh the
applicant and agent uh have heard enough
from our opinions from Members opinions
to uh give a view of to to have take a
view of where our considerations are
hopefully uh and to be able to speak to
officers and to look at where this can
be pushed further how how how these
policies can be addressed and how our
concerns can be addressed so I'd be
happy to propose that we do defer it and
that its officers take it back to uh
back to the applicant thank you
chair thank you Council Foster um have
we got a second of that proposal to
defer the uh to defer
this Council P thank you right we'll
uh we'll take a vote on that sorry could
I just ask
what exactly that
means deferring
it I'll let Adrian address that it's um
it would be chair without prejudice of
of our any further recommendation to
members as as offices we may still come
back with a similar recommendation but
it would be to allow the the applicant
to consider the particular concerns that
have been raised this afternoon in terms
of particularly around the um the
outbuilding in its own right but also
the the issues that councelor Foster's
made about concerns that actually is
this developed in accordance with with
those relevant policies and then it
would be a matter of us bringing back to
members for for further consideration
but that chair would would be without
prejudice to our recommendation back to
you as members you may choose to support
or not any recommendation but that that
would be in effect what we would go to
do what that would mean is we would come
back to members
with the scheme that either the
applicants had agreed they were happy to
go forward with or not so at least you
would know that whereas at the moment
they want the three buildings in effect
and all that goes with
it hopefully that that helps chair and
is reflective
of uh Council
dor thank you chair uh just to
clarify sorry thank you uh just to
clarify my earlier point just to make
absolutely clear the issues that I
clear on that is is the workshop and
this side this side building the one
that extends over the original uh
boundaries of the original building um
in regards to what councelor Foster said
I I understand that I'm sub I'm quite
new to this I don't think uh I while I'm
happy to agree with him on this that
deferring is probably the right course
of action in this instance I don't think
that we'd be setting a any sort of
precedent by looking this looking at
this again in future um because from my
reading of this on ss9 and sdc3 um this
hinges on whether this is viewed as
derel or reclaimed land it if it is
viewed as derel they are building as I
understand it on a previously developed
site that that is my understanding at
the moment I'm happy to be corrected and
that would you know influence future
decisions on my and when this come when
this comes back or if this comes back
should be vote for a deferment today
yeah Council Foster just apologies
[Music]
chair the only point I was going to make
chair in terms of the um issue that has
been alluded to around precedent Etc and
we've talked many times around this
table in terms of planning precedent and
you would normally consider each
application on its merits and seek to
identify that as the conditions and the
the issues relating to that set it aside
from others however there is the issue
that applicants and agents expect
consistency in your decision making so
you need to bear in mind that when you
come to make a decision on the
application in terms of consistency of
that decision making across situations
that may be considered or not similar
elsewhere in in the
district council Foster thank you chair
um on that on that point about Pro what
I'm concerned about is it's not giv a
precedence uh in planning but rather
than at this
[Music]
committee
can can we just try another
[Music]
microphone yeah yeah we're just trying
to address that thank
you
I'll wait for this to
connect I think it's
connected yeah thank you uh one of the
things if this comes before me me again
and I'm here at this committee one of
the things I'll be considering if it
does fit ss9 f much like Adrian said uh
earlier it's not just that it ticks the
box of devct or previously develop land
it's not got to have a greater impact on
that character of the country side than
the existing development it's got to
satis satisfy that part of it when it
reach es uh this committee and I've got
to be able to say I'm happy with that
that's one of the things I'll be looking
at uh if it comes before me again so um
saying that uh there's a motion that's
been uh proposed and seconded and chair
I'd like that motion to be uh put to the
vote
please sorry chair the motion's been
moved
by yes M by Council second by coun okay
okay so I think the essence Adrian from
your point of view is that
the the application pending further
clarification in terms of the uh
specific focus of the scheme and also
the relevant policy issues in terms of
precedent for the Comm defer to to go
back to the applicant to discuss the
various matters that have been raised by
by committee members particularly in
terms of the the scale and scope of the
scheme and as councelor Foster has
mentioned the the issue about policy SS
n and greater impact particularly and we
would then come back to to Meers we
might be able to a bit more information
in terms of dereliction as well so have
we got that right
members
yeah and the actual use of this Workshop
that bothers me because I read I'm off
again I all right it whether or not it's
going to be used as an industrial thing
or just literally home
thank
you uh right we're going to put this Mo
Council Foster yeah thank you chair on
that last point that could always be
addressed at a later stage as a
condition that it only be used that
point
then we should be ready to go right I
think we're ready to put this to the
vote to defer this uh yeah to a later
date the officers uh work um right it's
up on your screens now if people take a
vote
y right that's you Amin us we've got to
just confirming everyone voted that's
how they want to vote y right thank you
so the application is going to be
deferred right thank you thank you for
uh coming along and uh expressing your
views
uh right I now call call on the planning
officers to explain our next report item
seven appeals lodged and
determined thank you
chair just in terms of would you like to
wait
till the room's been
cleared yeah we we we'll wait until
the people have left
thanks
do we need
to
Tom
just uh right then members we'll uh move
on to item seven uh Now call on the uh
planning officers to explain the next
report uh appeals lodged and
determined thank you chair just in terms
of the the report you will see that in
the
last few weeks we've had a number of
appeals submitted for consideration
they're set out at paragraph
1.1 there's been no appeals allowed over
the past period but you will see there's
been two appeals dismissed and in
particular chair in view of the
discussion we've just had I would
recommend to members if you haven't
already you um take a look at the
decision um in respect of Mr Bailey's
appeal at Wy Moore which is not too far
distant from um the application site
that you've just been discussing and in
that instance there was a structure that
was given permission to be converted and
unfortunately um the building
was in effect demolished and Mr Bailey
had started constructing another
building which he then sought and
permission for and that has been
dismissed on appeal so members may find
that interesting in in relation to the
discussion that you've just had
um in terms of paragraph
1.4 um a
very pleasing decision from an from a a
council point of view in terms of green
belt development at Ridgeway again as
with all these cases always recommend to
members that you you look through the
appeal cases because they they provide
clear evidence of are we in accord with
with national and local policy are we
making decisions in in the correct form
and in that instance another very
pleasing decision in terms terms of
green belt development so happy to take
any questions chair um in the next um
report there will be
um couple of interesting decisions which
members will probably get either today
or tomorrow in respect of enforcement
issues at West Handley so you you may
well be well you will I'm sure be very
interested in those as well and uh and
Lisa will as
well uh thank you do we have any
questions Council
all members should be receiving them oh
get them in so I'm I'm hoping that and
if that isn't happening chair just be
really Keen to know because we we've now
sending that to all members so all
members across the council receiving all
the appeal decisions because the problem
we were having was keeping up to date
with planning committee members and and
that was changing um without as
necessarily keeping our our dat database
up to date so all members across the
council should be getting them in email
form and
if can I detail yeah they're attached
the the decision is attached and if that
isn't happening in any case I'd be
grateful to be advised because there are
as I say they're a really
important tool for us as officers and in
advising you and as you as members in
your role on the on the committee
chair okay thank you Adrian more
questions on
that uh thank you members uh I think
it's probably worth noting what Adrian's
just said on that actually that we we do
all take a look at that report for from
Wymore um and uh have a quick look at
that
um right do we agree to note the report
yeah yep okay thank you uh right um I've
got one matter of urgent business really
we just to wish Lisa all the
best as she's moving on and this is your
last meeting I believe it is so good
luck thank very okay pleasure
[Laughter]
it watching on
YouTube are you coming back for the next
meet I'll have a look on
YouTube right thank you colleagues uh
meet closed
thanks